[Music]  [Music]  it's very important for young Thai kids  any kids to be curious and ask questions  we're celebrating 10 years of the little  scientists house program in Thailand was  initiated by Her Royal Highness Princess  Maha Chakri Sirindhorn in 2010 a decade  of exploring how things work by asking  questions  lumely addicted console staff did you  have some say what am i lured you  Natalie Natalie in the past Thai  students learnt by memorizing to become  scientists of tomorrow it's important to  encourage kids to ask questions today  this is why we're so involved and why we  want to spread this program across  Thailand the little scientists house  program is in over 22,000 kindergartens  across Thailand our hope is to reach all  schools in Thailand to help children  become scientists of the future  [Music]